Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week, at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're going to be talking
about our preparations
for some upcoming trips.
Now that may sound like,
why are we going to
talk about preparations?
Well just wait, these are special trips.
'Cause these trips are special.
Well, I mean, we should say,
you're going on a solo trip.
Yeah.
And I'm going on a trip that
I visualized a lot in my mind.
And that may be a problem.
But you're not going solo.
But not to make me look bad.
We'll talk--
Yeah, right.
We'll talk about that in a little bit.
We'll talk about the fact
that I've planned my entire
trip to make you look bad?
Really?
That's a sign od dysfunction.
But I chose to go on this
trip first at this time.
And then you were like, "Well you know,
"we usually travel at the same time."
But you were like, "Well
I'm going to take my wife."
And I was like, "You trying
to make me look bad?"
And by my wife, I mean, your wife,
you're not taking my wife.
We'll have you talked to her lately?
I wonder what she's up to.
I mean, we're leaving,
tomorrow's the big prep day.
And then,
so 48 hours from right now,
we will both be on the road.
Hopefully, but there's
a lot of question marks
associated with that.
Enough to talk about
for an entire podcast.
Another question mark is,
where'd you get that shirt you're wearing?
I know this was your shirt.
No, that is my shirt.
There is no was about it.
You gave me this shirt.
No.
I have given you some shirts
that were too small for me.
That one fits me perfectly.
Well I feel like this shirt
is a little too big for me.
Yeah.
But,
there's an orange one and this
one, and they're the same.
And you said these don't work for me.
And I'm like, "Okay,
well I'll take these."
They're not the same. So, not a sponsor.
That's an Elwood shirt,
which I like, and I wear.
It's got a big neck.
It's got a bigger neck,
but it also, it's a little bit longer fit.
It's a little longer.
And those work and they haven't shrunk.
The orange one was like a $6 one,
like a blank that I got off of Amazon.
What I'll tend to do is
I'll buy blank shirts
that are the same kind of shirts
that we print on here at Mythical.
I don't even know what brand it is,
Next Level or something like that.
I'll find blanks, 'cause I
like to wear plain t-shirts.
But sometimes not everything's,
they're not always the same
size, depends on the color.
And that orange one got
a little bit too small.
There was another one with the orange one,
it was this one.
That one, I wasn't, I didn't--
What am I gonna do? I go
into your rack and take it.
I Didn't mean to give you that shirt.
Can I get it back?
What's in it for me?
There doesn't have to be--
Do you have another?
The orange shirt.
You can keep the orange one.
I don't like orange on me.
I gave it to you cause it didn't fit me.
Will you change the color
of the orange shirt?
I'll dye it for you.
Like tie-dye, bleach it?
I'll dye it, yeah.
Just stain it thoroughly
to where it looks like a different hue.
And then I'll give you this.
I mean, do you want it right now?
You want me to do this shirtless?
No. I do not want that.
Some people might, but I do not.
We also need to catch up.
Well, first of all, we need a cat update
because, the presentation.
There was quite a build up there.
Yeah, 'cause theoretically we
could have a kitten right now.
But the plan was, when
we get, Chris and I,
get back from our trip,
then we will get the cat.
Oh. So it's happening.
'Cause the kitten will be old enough.
We decided that we're
going to get this kitten.
And of course in the
presentation it was Yeti,
the white cat.
And then that cat, turns
out that cat was adopted.
That's what happens usually.
And she was like, "Well, I'll
just take the black cat."
which she's calling Opal.
But then I, and it may have
been right after we recorded,
I went home, or a few days later,
and there was this whole kerfuffle.
That cat was adopted out
from underneath her too.
You gotta act fast with cats.
Well, we were, they were,
Lilly and Chris were upset
because they did the paperwork,
the adoption paperwork,
the application that said,
this is the cat that we want.
We've been in contact with the cat.
Just to kind of clarify the whole thing.
And the application was approved.
And then the next day is when
they found out that the cat,
oh, somebody else came in
and adopted another cat.
But then because they were
willing to adopt two cats,
they were given preference
and they were given your cat.
Of course she didn't say, "Your cat."
And that just doesn't seem right to me.
It didn't seem right to any of us.
But ultimately, after the
person at the adoption agency
ended up saying, "Listen, you
know what? This is my fault."
It seems like if she had to do it again,
she would have given Lilly the cat,
but she was not going
to go take the cat back
from the people who adopted two kittens.
So the long and short of it
is we did not secure this cat.
The cat has been unsecured.
It has been adopted by another family.
Just get another black cat.
Along with a sibling.
Just get another cat.
I was like--
You had already settled
for the second cat.
Yeah, That's what I told--
Settle for a third.
Either that, or let's just not get a cat.
So, I mean, so are you saying that
when you get back from your trip,
you're going to go and
your gonna pick the cat?
A new cat?
Lilly was so mad.
Well I understand that.
That there's been no other plans made.
I think the assumption is
that there's some cooling off period,
where, whenever we talk about it,
she's just so hot under
the collar about it
that we can't get to,
Well let's actually look for another cat.
And I'm not pushing the issue.
I was not me that wanted a cat
Maybe this is part of the system.
Maybe they do this with
everyone, it's a test.
Let's tell them we gave their cat away
and see if they're a reasonable person.
Got to think about that.
Gotta think about everything.
Lilly let them have it and then--
She talk to them directly?
Yeah. Lilly got on the phone with the--
Good for her. You know what?
Listen. That's what these--
And I was really proud of her.
That's these kids should be doing.
Yeah, she talked to her on
the phone, it wasn't a text.
I know I sound like an old man a lot.
Well, I am, I'm 42.
I mean, 43, probably,
I'll be 43 about couple of
weeks after this comes out.
Listen.
You young folks, you
can't handle life's issues
either via text or via your parents.
Just gotta get on that phone.
Do something.
Yeah, I was surprised.
Take control of your own issues.
I was very proud of her
for getting on the phone.
Of course it didn't help.
And the moral of the story is, yeah,
you shouldn't have said that.
You should have said it
worked, convinced her.
Well it didn't work, I mean,
so now it's just, it's been like a week
of not really talking about it.
Cat cooling off period.
So we'll see what happens.
Okay. I'm waiting anxiously.
Now another thing that
we have to update you on.
Again, I don't know exactly
when this is coming out,
but I do know that it
will have been a few weeks
since this happened, but I,
well, no, you tweeted,
you tweeted something.
Oh, okay. The boot tweet.
Yeah.
Well, okay, yeah.
I tweeted, this is
Saturday night after I did
my listening party with Britain
and, let's see.
Where is this? Where's the text?
Scroll, scroll, scroll.
Well, it'd probably be under your Twitter.
There's another way to
do it, but you're just--
Yeah, just at 9:30 at night.
What I tweeted out was,
"Just got a text from Rhett that said,
come to living room to discuss boot."
That's it. No period, no
follow up, no nothing.
And I'm just staring at that.
Now don't, please don't
share the followup text yet.
Okay.
We'll get to that.
So that's what I tweeted.
I tweeted that and then--
Well, no, well you also
tweeted back at me.
You texted back to me, you're
like, "Can I tweet this?"
And I was like, "Sure, tweet it."
Yeah, yeah.
You tweeted it.
I responded to you.
The mythical beasts
who are tuned in to our
Twitter conversations.
It's a certain set. You
guys were very concerned.
There was a lot of conjecture
about what may have been meant,
whether or not I was at Links house.
Were are we going to discuss boot?
So right now we're about to clear up
the discussing boot controversy.
And let me tell you,
every single possible idea
that you have about it
is more interesting than
the actual explanation.
And that's why I've
let it sit for a while.
I have not heard the actual
explanation, except the--
The follow up text.
Except the followup text.
But I mean, my followup tweet,
when you did not tweet anything
back to my original tweet,
just got a text from @rhettmc that said,
come to the living room to discuss boot.
And then people are like,
"Seems very urgent."
"Just go meet up with him."
"He's waiting for you."
"You sure it's Rhett this time?"
And then I wrote back, I
tweeted, replied to myself,
just to give an update.
And I was like, "We are not in
the same house. I'm scared."
Which just seemed to
send people into a tizzy.
But I mean, the texts that
you sent back to me privately,
after come to living room to discuss boot,
was "Whoops, sorry."
"That was meant for Locke."
And then I said,
"Can't imagine how that text
"would not be strange
for anyone to receive."
Right.
So it was a...
You sent it to me. You
meant to send it to Locke.
I still have no clue
what you want to discuss boot with Locke.
Come to living room to discuss boot.
Let me tell you that the Link/Locke mix up
has happened before.
I can't, this is definitely
the funniest example of it,
but I go to my phone to text
someone, my son in this case,
and I just see, it's
like, I think I'm about to
press Locke, but I press Link.
And then next thing you
know, I've sent a text.
Anyway.
So I'm gonna make this short
cause it's uninteresting.
Locke sprained his ankle on Thursday.
And he's like me,
he's a hypochondriac.
And he has catastrophized
how bad the ankle sprain is,
and what it's gonna
mean, and all this stuff.
And he's had some issues
with his ankles. High arches.
And so he's like talking about,
"Dad, you gotta get me one of those boots.
"You gotta get me one of
those immobilizing boots.
"We got to go tomorrow and get it."
And I was like, "Locke, we just can't.
"There's no place you
can just pick this up.
"I can order you one like on
Amazon. It'll get here Monday."
Well, I needed to discuss that with him.
'Cause he was like, figure
out where we're going to go--
Hold on, I bet you were in living room.
And I was in the living room
and he was somewhere else.
And I texted him, "Come to
living room to discuss boot."
So you don't yell through
the house, you just text,
as a form of intercom.
We have Google home. So we
will sometimes broadcast.
That's right, you can do that.
But he was,
I had some reason to believe that
he was not next to a speaker.
I can't remember. I thought--
I've never used that feature by the way.
Oh, it's constantly happening.
You don't use the dinnertime feature?
If you say HG, cause
I'm not going to say it.
'Cause I don't want your
Google devices to go up.
That's considerate.
If you say, HG, it's dinner
time, she rings a bell.
Come and get it, ding, ding, ding.
Really?
And it rings everywhere,
at all your Google homes.
Oh, what? I didn't know about that.
We use it, in fact, this
morning as I was leaving,
I heard Jesse say,
"HG, broadcast, Shepherd, get up now."
'Cause she doesn't know, where,
he could be anywhere in the house asleep.
Well you can actually broadcast
directly to a person's room
now, that's a new feature.
In the past one month you can say,
"Broadcast to Shepherd's
room. Get up now Shepherd."
So Locke has a sprained ankle.
So you're making him come all the way
down all the stairs on his sprained ankle,
there's other stairs even
into the living room.
No I think he was outside.
The living room is the farthest point.
He was outside.
And also, again, I was
handling all this for him.
He's a 16 year old kid.
Let him let him discuss his own boot.
He should discuss boot in
his own mind, and buy boot.
Cause listen, we bought boot.
And yesterday boot arrived.
Yeah.
And he tried to put boot on
and I could tell he could
not figure boot out.
How hard is it to figure out boot?
Well, it's a complex boot.
It's just a bunch of Velcro straps, right?
I know, but there's a
valve, and it inflates.
And there's things that you stick in.
There's a valve?
Yeah. It was $75.
So probably not all of them.
So I said, "I knew this
was going to happen."
I was like, I saw
they're fumbling with it.
I was like, "You figuring it out?"
And he's like, "Not really."
I was like, "Well I believe in you."
And I just walked away, because
I'm just, I don't want to,
they got to do things on their own, man.
One of these days, it's just
going to be you and boot,
and no help.
Does that count as discuss boot.
Like what you just talked about.
Does that count?
Yeah. I believe in you. Yeah
No, just that part was
discuss boot as well.
Anytime we talk about
boot, is discussing boot.
But people thought so
many different things.
Like, lots of people
were like, "Is it book?
"Are they writing another
book? Discuss book?"
I would text you, come to the living room.
Some people say you left the Y off.
Booty?
Come to living room--
Discuss booty.
I'm not going to be showing
up for that appointment.
Yeah. So it's much less
interesting than you all thought,
And it's an actual boot.
But I did go into my living room.
You weren't there.
Yeah.
Which I tweeted, I believe.
Well we just caught
everybody up on everything.
We're so caught up.
Now we can move into the future
and talk about our big plans.
I have this sense that we're
gonna talk about these plans
and then something's going
to happen to one of us
and this is going to be--
Oh gosh.
I don't know, it's just--
I hope it's you.
I have this sense of impending doom
and I almost wish I didn't say anything.
And there's good reason for
that, which we'll get into.
But first we want to remind you
about the Vote Like a Beast campaign.
votelikeabeast.com.
Check it out.
Just go to the site. It can't hurt.
Yeah, and another thing
I love about the internet
is I love all the conspiracy theories
about Vote Like a Beast.
You can't do anything today.
Like, if you say, listen,
this is a nonpartisan
effort to get the vote out.
No, no, no. That's not good enough.
People are like, "No way
it's nonpartisan. No way."
This is the comments.
Is it in a particular place?
Like, is this on Facebook?
Where are you seeing this?
No. Facebook is a cesspool.
I don't go to Facebook.
But the, I just saw it in,
when I first posted just
the picture on Instagram,
which was just Vote Like a Beast,
and just said something about,
inform yourself about
the candidates, whatever.
It was like, oh man, it just,
first of all, you've
got the partisan stuff
happening on the post, which
I get it's the election.
But the conspiracy theories
about the color choices of this,
the fact that the beast hand is red
and the other hands are blue.
And it's just like, I love it.
And the text is white.
Oh my gosh, it's red, white, and blue.
Yeah, 'cause we're in America.
But anyway, it was...
Next year we'll do, or next
year, four years from now,
we'll do green and yellow.
No, we won't. We'll do
red, white and blue again.
What is green and yellow?
I just, it's not red and--
I know that, but like what is that?
Like Brazil, I guess.
It's for the elections in Brazil.
There's a little blue, in the Brazilian.
Am I wrong about that?
There's a little bit of blue somewhere?
I think there's a blue
circle of some kind.
There's a symbol that's blue.
A little blue in it.
That's what we'll do.
Yeah. Anyway--
I mean, it can work for
any global election.
Just so you know, it is a conspiracy.
We are backed by the Illuminati.
And you go to votelikeabeast.com
at your own peril.
So there you go, votelikeabeast.com
'Cause watch out,
you might find the tools necessary to vote
and to connect your actual
beliefs and passions
with the candidates
that are on your ballot.
Watch out.
The best one was a guy that said,
"Interesting. They're finally big enough
"for the government is using them."
And there was like 20 thumbs up.
So this guy and 20 other people are like,
"Yeah, that is interesting,
the government's using them."
Government's using us.
I love being used by the government.
It's, you know,
I'm glad you can have a
sense of humor about it.
That's why I don't read the
comments because it just,
it perplexes me and it's hard for me to--
Don't be perplexed, man.
To see it in a comedic light.
People believe all kinds of stuff.
Okay, votelikeabeast.com.
All right.
So, as you said, this
is a solo trip for me.
And this is something that
I have been planning for,
I've been intending for a long time.
So ever since I started going to therapy,
a couple of years ago,
one of the things that my
therapist does on a regular basis,
is take solo trips.
Like, he'll go take like a,
he can do like twice a year.
He'll do over a week long trip.
Well that's a sabbatical.
If you go over a week
you're taking a sabbatical.
He's always talked about,
and I've known lot's of friends who,
they kind of got into a
rhythm where each year
both the husband and the wife
would take like a week long solo trip.
And people have talked about this being,
he's been encouraging it
for a really long time,
both for me and for Jessie.
And Jessie is heading off on a solo trip
a few weeks from now.
And again, he's just like,
it's just a different vibe.
Especially when you are,
you've never done it before.
And each person has their own reasons
why they would want to do it,
and what might be the benefits of it.
But he's just talked
about, he's just like,
"You unplug and you kind
of have an intention,
"and you just get out there
"and you don't really know
exactly what's going to happen."
But he's just like,
at this point I couldn't do without them.
They are like my reset button, right?
And you hear people talk about this.
Like, I don't know if
it's an urban legend,
but like Rivers Cuomo goes
off for a month every year
into a silent, he does
like a silent retreat.
So he doesn't speak
for a month every year.
There's places you can go.
Yeah.
Like monasteries, I think, and do like--
That would be an option.
Silent retreat.
A yoga retreat would also be nice.
Especially out here in
Cali. There's plenty stuff.
I mean, it is a tenet of mythicality.
I mean, in the book of mythicality
we devoted a whole chapter
to isolate yourself with yourself.
And so on this very
podcast, we talked about
the first solo trips that
we each took years ago.
So if you're interested
in our first solo trips,
you can look that up.
I went to Slab City, which is like
out in the desert below Joshua Tree.
And you went--
Joshua Tree.
'Cause we didn't go at the same time.
I don't think so, yeah.
Yeah, you went off into some BLM land,
which Bureau of Land Management.
Yeah. You have to clarify that.
I noticed that the other day.
'Cause I was looking for
some BLM information about--
You can camp anywhere
on Black Lives Matter.
I was looking for some BLM,
Bureau of Land Management,
information for dispersed
camping and it's just like,
oh yeah, yeah. okay. Yes.
The hashtag has been taken over.
You have to spell it out now.
Which is great.
That's good.
That's good. That's really good.
So yeah, and that trip, that
was only a night or two.
I think it was, mine was three nights.
You went longer than I did.
But I wasn't alone.
I went to Slab City and
interacted with people.
I was alone a lot, but not the whole time.
To clarify, I'm not
necessarily going to be
out of human contact.
But let me just--
I thought you were.
Well, no, I am going to
be out of human contact
for most of the time, but I'm not,
I'm going to places where there is likely
to be other people at times.
So it's not like I'm not
going to speak to people.
I'm not going off into the wilderness,
completely isolated in
one area for six days.
'Cause I think that's what it is,
I think it's five nights, six days.
But you could get, you
could certainly go two days.
Oh easily.
Without seeing or talking to anybody
based on what I've heard of your plans.
Well that's kind of, I mean,
we'll get into like why
that might be the case.
So one of the things that my
therapist has talked about,
and this is, I mean,
this is not exclusive
knowledge that he has.
This is just common knowledge,
I think, at this point.
But most people who go off
and spend time alone are like,
you don't really experience the benefit.
Anybody I've ever heard talk
about a meditation retreat.
You really don't experience
much of the benefit
unless you get past like day three, right?
A lot of times, right around day three,
some people say day five,
which is like almost a total time
that I'm going to be out there,
is when something clicks.
And you're like, you know--
When you really start to go crazy.
That's what some people
may be thinking right now.
It's like, if I've never
been alone that long,
is that, are we talking about
a breaking point or a break through point?
They might be one of the same.
But this trip, for me, represents--
But that's something,
your therapist tells you
is that it doesn't need
to be a short trip.
It needs to be as long as
you can make it so you can
get past that turning point.
Well, and specifically,
and this is for me,
but it probably applies
to a lot of people.
It takes a couple of days.
I mean, I notice this
when I travel on vacation
just with the family,
it takes a couple of days
for me to finally adjust
to the pace of a vacation.
I think about so many things.
I am constantly, have
a low level of anxiety
about like 28 different things
that are related to us professionally.
I was thinking about
this the other day that,
you guys know a lot of
the things that we do.
You see a lot of the
things that we do publicly,
sort of the ongoing things that we do,
but we don't talk about what
it's like to run a company
and to grow a company and to deal with
all the issues that come with that.
We don't talk about all the other projects
that we're trying to get off the ground.
We don't, there's a whole lot of things
that we don't talk about,
just because we keep
some things to ourself.
We talk about a lot.
But sometimes it hits me,
even when I'm sitting down
and trying to meditate, and
the point of the meditation
is to just focus on my breath
and not think about anything else.
Monkey brain, right?
I have monkey brain, just like
most everybody and I can't
just stop thinking about a
million different things.
So what I've been told by
people who try to unplug
is that, listen, it takes
a few days just for,
to grab all the knobs and turn them off.
You're just finding another
knob and turning it off.
And for me, the whole
point of the trip is,
I've been on this quest to try
to connect with myself more.
And I don't say, I'm not saying
that in a self absorbed way,
I'm saying that in a, I tend
to be very much in my head.
Don't spend a lot of time in my heart.
Don't spend a lot of
time understanding what,
knowing what I'm feeling.
Really getting into my feelings
and understand what that means.
Just knowing myself, right?
And every step I've taken
towards that has been beneficial.
Not only for me,
but for all the people
in my life who I love.
And I've been doing, one
sort of outward manifestation
of what I'm trying to do internally
has been me growing my
beard and my hair out.
I talked about that on an
episode of Ear Biscuits.
And I've been intending
to do this solo trip
for a really long time,
thinking that it was going to be 2020.
Of course COVID happened, and so things,
a lot of people's plans
got turned upside down.
But I finally got it on the books.
You know, we said, let's
just carve the time out
and then we'll start figuring
out what we're gonna do.
So this was a couple of
months ago that we were like,
okay, this is when the
time is going to be.
It was before, before COVID hit, I think.
It wasn't, it wasn't for me.
I am going North from Los Angeles.
One of the things that my
therapist has done many times,
and is kind of into,
is going throughout through
the Western United States
and going to hot springs.
And I'm a huge hot springs guy.
I love hot springs. I love hot water.
And I'm, I'm not, I don't
believe a lot of woo stuff.
So I'm not, I don't necessarily think
that there's some like spiritual thing
that's gonna happen to
me at these hot springs.
Maybe I'm open to it, but
that's not why I'm going.
I just love hot springs.
And I love the idea.
He sent me these pictures
of places he's gone,
where he drives his
four wheel drive vehicle
through these mountains and
comes to this hot spring.
And then he's got this
hot spring to himself.
And there's nobody there.
I mean, it is really cool.
It's mesmerizing to think about it.
'Cause you look on a map
and you can see, I mean,
when we've gone off-roading,
our first experience with
hot springs was when we went
on that trip to Death Valley.
And then you get to this one little oasis
in the middle of this
valley that has nothing.
But way down there in
the bottom of the valley
You see there's some palm trees.
I mean, just what you
would think of an oasis.
And there was a hot spring there
and there was some naked people.
We talked about that on a GMM
episode when we came back.
And those are more, that's like on a road
that most cars can get
to, there might be an RV.
Some of the ones that he's shown me,
that I may or may not be able to get to,
are more isolated than that.
Yeah. You'll just see on the
map, it'd say hot springs,
but it looks like it's
in the middle of nowhere.
And some of them don't even,
aren't even on the map.
So, okay. So anyway.
This is where I,
and I don't want to get
too in the weeds on this,
but the thing that is very,
sort of the key struggle
that I'm dealing with at this point,
two days out from departure,
is what I've been dealing
with for the past two months.
Which is the balance of being prepared
versus having unrealistic or
even specific expectations.
Because for me, the whole exercise,
the whole point of the trip,
is to not want to accomplish anything.
My life
and my brain is sort
of completely centered
around accomplishing things, right?
And I can't vacation without thinking
that I need to learn how to do,
I need to learn how to surf.
I need to, I have these
things that I get in my mind
that I feel like I have to accomplish
in order to make it worth it.
And when you go on a solo
trip, there is this like,
well, I've got to come
back with some wisdom.
I've gotta come back with something.
But also I, what if I
can't find these places?
Or what if I get there
and there's people there?
What if I get there, and
the big, huge question mark
that has suddenly sprung up in these plans
is the freaking wildfires
that are consuming our state.
And I'm not driving.
I am driving directly towards one of them,
but it's one that's not as
big as some of the other ones.
But if you look at satellite imagery
of the state of California,
there's smoke everywhere.
I mean, wherever I go,
I'm going to be
covered in smoke to some degree.
And not only that, but just last night,
because of this latest fire,
it was a bunch of fires
that just happened.
Having just started recording those.
I mean, there's been
multiple fires, but there's
a couple more that just
started over the weekend.
And now the Santa Ana winds are coming in.
They've closed all the national forest.
So like Sequoia's closed,
Inyo is closed.
And both Sequoia and
Inyo, especially Inyo,
are ones that I would
have been camping in.
That's right, yeah.
And so I don't know what that
means for all the BLM land.
'Cause you've got the
Bureau of Land Management,
which is like, usually crappier land,
that wasn't good enough to be designated
as a national park or a forest,
but you can do disperse camping.
And I've got this rooftop
tent on the FJ cruiser.
That, basically,
if I could find a place
to park, I can camp.
But there are no fires
allowed, and not just no fires,
no stoves, no gas stoves.
So you can't even get hot water.
As of last night, you
cannot have a gas stove fire
anywhere in a national
forest in California.
But that, what does that mean about BLM?
I've got my little bullet water boiler
that I'm just, to make
like quick meals and stuff.
I won't do that in a forest,
in a national forest.
But I'm going to do it on
BLM land 'cause I got to eat.
But I mean, there's no fire risk in that.
What you don't need to
do is you don't need
to fire off one of those
gender reveal rockets.
Basically, that's where this is all about.
I'm going to go into the desert
and do a gender reveal of myself.
That's why, I mean, that's what it said,
that the fire South of us started
by a freaking gender reveal party.
I know.
Well, why, what are they doing
having a gender reveal party?
And it was over a hundred
degrees and they're outside
firing off a pink or blue
smoke that caught fire.
They tried to put it out.
It goes over the hill
and then they evacuating
thousands of people.
And did you hear what they're saying?
They're going to--
Nightmare.
They're going to make
that family be responsible
to pay for the damage of the fire.
What do you mean? Are they billionaires?
Cause otherwise, no.
I mean, they should obviously
be held accountable,
but I saw an article
like family has to pay.
I was like, pay? Out of what?
They're sorry. That's all you can,
I mean, they learnt, they've
been made an example of.
So that's complicating
things because fires are--
Fires are so sad.
I don't have a, I have,
I've got all these apps and
all these maps downloaded.
And I've got like, my family laughs at me
because every single weekend I'm out there
putting stuff into the truck
and I've got these drawers
in the back of the FJ now
with all my stuff in it.
I am so prepared.
And I'm really excited
about the rooftop tent.
Oh yeah, that's nice.
But my route--
I plan on using that.
My route takes me up into,
basically heading up towards Mammoth
and that whole valley
all the way up on the 395
has got, there's hot springs and stuff.
And then my options after
that, depending on how I feel,
I could go all the way
up to Northern Nevada.
to Idaho if it hits me.
But I think I'm going to get
too far away at that point.
And it would be too tough to come back.
But there's wildfires
all along this route.
And so I just don't
know, every single night
I'm going to have an
intention on the general area
in which I would like to
sleep and kind of bed down.
But it's so up in the air, there's no,
I'm not doing any formal campgrounds.
I have a portable toilet
with a privacy pop-up thing.
I have a solar shower.
I am going to be
completely self sufficient.
I don't have to stop
anywhere except for gas.
Let me share my plans a little bit.
And, cause I, and then
I want to come back to
what is going to be your practice,
'cause I'm, I'm interested in that.
But just to kind of skip over to my thing.
Yeah, once you carved out those dates,
it's so much easier to say,
"Oh, I'm going to do the same dates.
"I'm going to plan my own trip."
And I really like the idea
of doing another solo trip.
And I definitely have
this feeling that I could
really benefit from that and
I definitely want to do it.
But I've had this thing that,
I've told you about the vans.
I started this hashtag vanlife stuff.
I've started following all these people
who live out of these
Mercedes Sprinter vans
that have been modded out
with a bed and a kitchen.
And some of them have a bathroom inside
and they can have four wheel drive.
Oh, it just looks so good on Instagram.
Oh, just look at those
pictures of that person.
Just a van in the middle of nowhere.
And I'm like, I can see this in my future.
And I start talking to you about--
You can see it in you're future.
I'm gonna get one of these vans.
Can you see it in Christy's future?
Because it's in her future an this point.
Yes, I'm really
romanticizing this idea of,
not selling my house and living in a van,
but having this van,
it's basically the cool
hipster version of an RV.
We had our RV trip to Grand
Canyon a few years back
and Lando was excited to do it again
and Christy had a good
time but the older kids,
it just didn't resonate
that much with them.
And I'm like, well, I
can see in retirement,
me and Christy are gonna--
Be that couple.
It's like, once Lando is out of the house.
So like, you know--
Yeah, when he's 14, you're
going to send them off early.
Well let's just say eight years from now.
It's like, I could see that we
could do something like that.
Me and Christy could just
have these van excursions.
And she can see this as well?
I'm starting, I started to
show her pictures on Instagram.
I was like, isn't that cool?
Look at where they are.
How does she respond to that?
There's this specific
one that floats around.
And it's a point of view shot of someone
getting up out of the bed
in their Sprinter van,
going over to the burner and
taking the hot coffee in a mug,
opening the door to the
Sprinter van and then--
I've seen this.
Jump, then walking out
of the Sprinter van,
walking onto this little
dock and then jumping
into this beautiful mountain
lake, with the coffee.
Are you going to make those
kinds of videos on your trip?
And I'm like, I'm showing this to her.
And I'm like, we're going to
make these types of videos
in our retirement years.
And then I'm like, you know
what? Screw retirement.
I want to know now if this is even viable.
So I bought one. No. You can
rent these Sprinter vans.
This is like, there's a
site called outdoorsy,
which is like the Airbnb for RVs.
Does the having a bathroom?
The first one I was going to
rent didn't have a bathroom.
But then I was like, you know what?
This is so much about, so much hinges
on us having a good
experience, me and Christy.
And again, it's just the two of us.
We're not taking the kids.
It's like, if she hates this,
there's, I see no way forward.
Is this a bathroom you can take a shit in?
So I'm like, I'm renting
one with the bathroom.
So it's a toilet that,
yeah, you can crap in there.
And the toilet is in the shower.
So it's a toilet in a shower.
Well I shit in the shower already
Sign me up.
It's a shower with a grateless drain.
Wow.
No, you just, you put the lid down
and you can sit on the lid of the toilet
or like, I dunno, I guess hover.
Where does it go though?
Where does the feces go?
Onto the highway. No, it
goes into a container.
Yeah, and then you take that
container around with you
and it makes the whole van smell.
No, well, I don't know.
Maybe the technology's gotten better.
You have to test it out.
I can sus it out for you.
There's a seal. There's definitely--
There's a seal down there that eats it.
That's why it costs so much, '
cause you have to have an
environment for a seal.
That poor seal, man.
That's what you should feel bad about,
that you got to seal this that's eating
you and your wife's crap the whole trip.
C thought Sea World was bad.
And it's.
When we did the RV it was like,
there was no crapping in the
RV toilet, that was our rule.
Just like when we were on tour.
And that was based on
our experience in 2008,
being on an RV and somebody saying,
don't nobody crap in this thing.
No, but we gonna crap in this thing,
and we're going to figure it out.
We're going to see,
that's part of the test.
Otherwise these other Sprinter vans
that don't want to dedicate
the internal space to a shower,
they'll have a shower hanging off the back
and then they have a portable
toilet, like what you have,
and you just you'll just do
it in the middle of the van
or you'll do it with a curtain around you.
What you're talking about mine.
Yeah, mine is a, it is a, it
folds up to like a briefcase,
but then the legs come out,
and then you sit on it,
and there's a bag that basically,
and I've got like 12 bags or something.
Like a Diaper Genie?
It's basically like a diaper kind of bag.
And so, and I was reading the reviews
and this one mom was like,
"Our family of five used one
bag for the three day trip."
And I'm like, what?
But see, I think, what it
is is you take that bag
and you seal it up and then you put it.
So I've got the trasharoo which is my out,
it's the trash on the
outside of the truck,
that's on the back spare.
And then I think you just take that bag
and you put it out there, so it's outside.
And so it's not in your car.
You can't do that in bear country,
but I don't think you're
going to bear country.
You're going to--
Yeah, well I would be going,
and I do have bear spray, by the way,
I've got two cans of bear spray.
If I go to the West of 395, which is where
you're getting up closer to
the Sequoia and everything,
that's bear country, If I
were to go hiking or whatever.
But you're not going there anymore.
But the problem is, is that's
where all the fires are.
So I'm probably going
to go on the East side.
There might be bears out there.
You're saying the bears,
you're not talking,
you're talking about just the
trash being on the outside?
Yeah, yeah.
If I'm in a place that I
think that there's bears
then I'll put everything inside.
So you can boondock,
which is basically you can camp in your,
you can car camp anywhere
that is X amount of feet
off of a road on either
national forest or BLM land.
And you can't start fires everywhere,
or really anywhere right now.
But you have this,
there's a sense of freedom
that you don't have to reserve a campsite.
I mean, with COVID you can't
really reserve campsites
anywhere that's that the
best destinations anyway,
they were already reserved
and the capacity was severely taken down.
But my plan was, we were
going to go up the coast
to Big Sur and we were going to,
we're going to camp there one night
and then we're going to
keep going up to Monterey.
And then we're going to
go across to Yosemite.
I mean, when I made these plans,
the state was not burning.
But then all of a sudden
Big Sur caught on fire.
Yeah, it's all burning.
So I was like, well that's
going off of the list.
I'm just going to go to Yosemite
and we can stay outside of the park.
There's places you can stay,
spots you can stay at, I should say.
But now the air quality there is so bad.
The fires, at least right
now, aren't in Yosemite,
but there's so much smoke coming in
that it is not going to
be a good experience.
There's still a chance we may go,
but I'm pretty much have decided
that we're not going to Yosemite.
So now I'm like, I was
literally just looking at
the fire map of the
Western United States and
trying to figure out where we
could go that wasn't on fire.
And I was like, I think
Utah is hard to burn.
'Cause if you look at, just
based on the fire maps,
now I think I'm going to Utah.
Now Zion is very restricted.
Yeah, you got to get a
shuttle to go in there.
So I don't think we're
going to Zion National Park.
But, my understanding,
because I may end up in Utah.
So my route, one of my routes
takes me all the way to Utah
and then down through Zion,
and I'm just, I would still
just be on BLM, National
Forest land and stuff,
not going into the actual national parks.
If you get too far into Utah,
there's just not a lot of burn.
I mean, I'm speaking out of turn here,
but that's just the impression I get.
It's a bunch of rock
formation, there's no forests.
That's why all the fires
are West of the 395,
because even on the Eastern side of the,
so I guess that's the Eastern Sierras.
You just look at a satellite map.
It's like, it's, there's just
not a lot of vegetation there.
But I'm trying to find a
place that's not wicked hot.
It's not going to be
that hot at elevation.
I think we're going to Bryce Canyon,
or we're going around that area.
But again, we're just gonna,
we can find places to,
we're doing the same thing you're doing.
I'm just doing it in a really nice van.
So that I'm glamping and
you're just roughing it.
I mean, mine's gonna be,
it's not really roughing it.
I mean, this, it's not,
it's not glamping, but it's
easier than regular camp.
And the, I mean, the whole idea for me
is the, is to be like,
I don't know exactly where
I'm gonna park tonight
and then roll this tent out.
I want to be alone, right?
And so my philosophy, going into this,
is I'm driving North,
kinda gonna feel it out.
And I'm doing as much as I can
to literally like follow my instincts,
follow my heart, wherever might go.
It's an embodiment practice, right?
It's like, I'm physically going somewhere.
I don't have specific plans
and I'm going to take it as it comes.
And I'm gonna try to have an attitude,
correct me if I'm wrong, of embracing
whatever situation presents itself.
No expectations.
And that is a very difficult
thing for me to do,
because I'm thinking about
like, I've been looking at this,
looking at these maps and like thinking,
oh, I could go to this one.
Or am I going to be in
the mood to drive that far
if I want to go to this one?
What if I get there and it's
closed because of the fires?
Or it's closed for some other reason?
Or there's just a bunch of people there,
and I can't like, or in
many of these places,
there's a bunch of naked people there.
I don't mind that, but what
if I wanted to get naked?
Am I gonna get naked
with a bunch of people that I don't know?
Anything's on the table.
So the whole, the exercise is to let go.
Are you, if you show up
at a place, a spring,
and there's naked people there,
what are you going to do?
I'm just gonna get in with
my bathing suit on, probably.
If they're naked?
Yeah. I don't, I mean--
Just be naked.
I haven't thought about it. You know what?
I'm going to wait
and I'm going to follow
my heart in the moment.
If my heart says, let it all hang out.
It is going to be hard.
It would be hard for me,
I'll put it this way,
to not be thinking about
the report that I would
come back and give to you.
I mean the last solo trip, it,
there was meaningful things that happened.
But I do remember
constantly thinking about
how it was going to,
what kind of stories I was
going to be able to tell
that would make it more valuable,
but not in, that's not
the value you seek here.
But I talked, so I
talked about this aspect.
I actually, I hesitated
even talking about this trip
for this very reason, right?
And I talked about this whole
process with my therapist.
'Cause I said, I have a tendency
for a couple of things to happen.
Number one, I can be so focused on
not accomplishing something that,
that becomes something
I'm trying to accomplish.
I'm so focused on letting go that
if I feel like I can't let go,
then I feel like I haven't
met the expectation
of letting go of expectations.
So you really get inside
your own head, right?
But the other thing is,
is I think that I have to
have something to bring back.
And that can be, this is what happened
in my mind and my heart
while I was on this trip.
This is the epiphany that I had.
This is the realization that I had
at the third day, in the
middle of a meditation,
while I was tracking the sun, you know?
Or some funny has gotta happen.
So I've got the story
of whether or not I got
naked at the spring,
so I can come back on
Ear Biscuits and tell it.
And so my mission,
and again, there's really no way
to let go of this seeming like a mission
is to not have a mission
and to literally be like,
I don't, I'm not trying to
get myself into situation.
I'm not trying to take,
a lot of times we'll do
something or take a risk.
Like the time that I went to
that yoga class on my, solo,
we've taken a couple of solo.
I went to Joshua Tree one time.
But then another solo trip
is when I went to the beach
and I took in that yoga class.
And I was the only guy in there.
And it was a hilarious story.
There's a part of me that
went to that yoga class,
knowing that something funny might happen
that I could talk about on Ear Biscuits.
And I like living life
like that in certain ways,
in some ways, because I feel like
it leads me into better experiences.
But for this trip, I can't even promise
that I'm going to even
tell you how it went,
because it may be that I get something
that I feel like is just for me
and to share it would
make it, would ruin it.
So it may be that I'll
wait and share it later.
Cause I honestly, I don't,
I'm just trying to be open.
I am going to try to
make contact with aliens.
That is one of the things
that is going to happen.
Well, okay.
You're talking about
after that Netflix rec.
No, I know we we've talked,
there's been a number of
documentaries that we've watched.
Well, okay. So again--
That seems like a totally different path.
Yeah, we'll talk about this more later,
but, and here's the thing,
I don't believe that any of this is real,
but I'm just trying to be a person
who doesn't just conclude things
before being open to them.
And the whole Dr Steven Greer thing,
he's got a couple of
documentaries on Netflix.
He's the guy that had some access,
he worked at area 51 or whatever,
and he swears that
there's extra terrestrials
and they are, people are
in contact with them.
And then he has this whole
app where the idea is
that through meditation,
usually group meditation,
you can make contact with these aliens.
Now do I believe that this
is what's actually happening?
I would be so surprised if
that's what's actually happening,
but if it was what was actually happening,
wouldn't it be cool.
You know what I mean?
And so I'm just, again, coming from,
and a lot of this is continuing
to peel back the layers
of spending my entire life,
up until about 10 years ago or so,
really entrenched in an
evangelical worldview.
And one of the things that
comes along, for me personally,
with the evangelical
worldview, is just the belief
that you have arrived
at the ultimate truth.
I specifically remember,
even as a college student,
thinking, man it's so cool that
I believe the correct thing.
It's so cool that I know
that Jesus is the only way
to have a connection with
the creator of the universe,
and that I have a relationship with him,
and that I have arrived at this truth
that is the ultimate truth.
I remember thinking that
as a college student.
And 20 years later, I'm at this
place where it's just like,
the only thing I know is
that I don't know anything.
And it's a completely
different place to be.
But when you have this worldview
that it's all about having
this systematic theology,
all this stuff kind of wrapped up together
and it's kind of impenetrable, right?
And you're not really supposed to poke it.
And if you do poke it,
you're supposed to do it
for the sake of just building it up
and make it even making it even stronger.
To me, it's a good
exercise for me to be like,
now I have absolutely no reason to believe
that I'm going to have
contact with aliens,
but what does it feel like to sit down,
in the middle of the desert,
and I actually bought,
because they suggested
that you buy this chair.
That is one of those chairs,
the antigravity chair,
basically that you can kinda lean back.
You float? Okay, a recliner.
It's basically a recliner
for the desert or the beach.
An alien recliner.
And stare at the sky.
Does it, it points your butt hole
in the right place for a probe?
Right, yeah. It opens
you straight up to it.
There's going to be a moment where I am--
Just relax, let it in.
In a place where I'm out there.
It's just me and nature.
And I'm going to be open to
extra terrestrial interaction.
Now, Rhett--
And if it happens, I will talk about it.
We remember what happened
when you got scared on
your solo trip and you ran
into your tent and watched
Superbad on your laptop.
I certainly expect that that
is going to be a struggle.
I certainly expect--
You're gonna get scared.
That being scared, and
the funny thing about that
is that I actually could hear the highway
and see cars a couple of miles away.
I'm going to be in some places,
if I can get to the places
that I want to go, where,
like I have a satellite phone, FYI.
'Cause I'm going to be by
myself and I'm going to be
well outside of any sort of cell service.
I've got a satellite phone
that sends, oh and by the way,
you're listed as the
second emergency contact
behind my wife, so,
which may not be great,
'cause you're going to
be on your own trip.
But I will have the ability to do an SOS.
I have the ability to text
and basically text my location
and I can get somebody to come rescue me,
for a lot of money, if
things get real bad.
Okay.
But I plan, I am definitely
going to get scared.
I definitely relate to
the expectation thing.
I mean,
in general, in my life,
I'm trying to deal with,
how I place expectations on things,
and how I seek to control
things, and perfect things.
And one of the questions
that I'm learning to ask is
what is my desired outcome?
Because I've, and through that,
I noticed that a lot
of the things that I do
and actions that I take to assert control
that make me feel good,
actually don't move me
towards the desired outcome,
if I were to state what that is.
Now that's actually different than,
I think you're describing
an exercise that is,
let go of desire for an outcome.
So I'm not going to say that.
Whoa, you're moving the whole table.
Well, you keep hitting the
table, and it's making noise,
and I'm trying to--
Well, what you're doing
is not making noise.
I made it worse.
That got it. That's good enough.
That's basically where it was.
Just embrace the wobbliness of the table.
This is what we found. Here we are.
Right. That's good. This is good exercise.
Be here now.
And I usually don't care
about this kind of thing.
Usually you would be the
one that cared about it.
I know. I was making a point.
Okay. Good.
I don't remember it because
you shimmied the table.
That was a test.
Aggressively.
It was a test.
I think those are, I mean,
they're two different,
knowing what my desired outcome
is for me and stating that
is just a, is an exercise to help me know
if I'm fixating on things
for the wrong reason,
just for the sake of control.
I think it's just a different exercise
what you're doing.
But I do think there's
an element of that for me
in this trip as well, that I'm trying to.
Okay, my desired outcome
is to have
a quality experience with Christy,
for us to have a good time together.
For us to come back and have
a good time. Just period.
You know, we had to cancel
our 20 year anniversary trip.
We were going to go to Big
Sur and stay in this cabin.
It was going to be really cool.
We had to cancel all of
that because of COVID.
And instead of trying to
rebook something like that,
I'm going with this van
dream, test type thing.
But yeah, I could very easily
put so much pressure on her
to have a good time,
and to like this thing,
and to embrace my dream
and fantasy for us,
like living the van life.
Or/and put so much pressure on myself
to create an experience
that would win her over.
Versus this may be the only
experience we have in a van.
It may suck. It may be great.
But it's gonna, we're gonna be together.
And it's, I just want to
set it up for quality.
And it's not about going
to a certain destination
and then saying, okay,
well if we go here, these are the pictures
all of these people take on Instagram.
These are the things we gotta see, okay.
That means we've got to do this trail.
We got to hike this trail.
Well that means we've got
to get on this shuttle.
That means we've got a park here.
That means we've got to, you know,
all of these things that are about,
well my desired outcome is not
to have Instagramable moments
or be able to say that I did,
when I say I went to Bryce
Canyon and someone says,
Oh, did you do the so-and-so?
It doesn't matter if my
answer is yes or no to them.
It's interesting how I can
fall into that trap so easily.
It's like, unless I meet someone
who knows more than me about
something that I'm doing,
if I don't meet their expectations,
then I failed because I haven't done,
I haven't had a perfect trip.
And there's a fear--
Oh well, you didn't see the so-and-so.
And then there's the
fear of missing out too.
I mean, I remember the first time
we went to Disney world
with my wife's family, right?
So this is a big trip.
Her parents, I guess, at that point,
we may or may not have had any kids.
I can't remember.
But my brother and sister
in-law had at least a kid.
And then we had Gaga and Papa with us.
May they both rest in peace,
but they were both alive at the time.
Okay, that makes it easier.
And the idea,
so what I did,
when I found out we were
going to Disney world.
Itinerary, man.
And here's, the funny
thing is, I talk about it,
like I, when somebody,
when your best friend is as
efficiency driven as you are,
you begin to think that you're not.
You begin to think that you're
this happy go-lucky guy,
until you interact with normal people
or people who are on the
opposite end of the spectrum.
And then you realize
that, I realized that I am
so much more concerned about
planning and efficiency
then my wife's family.
And also, probably, than
the average person, right.
Or I'm probably somewhere in
the middle of the spectrum.
But for this trip I bought the book.
And I was like, okay,
we've got five days here.
These are the parks we need to visit.
This is the, we need to
literally go around the park
in this direction, we need to
get fast passes for this ride.
We need to skip this ride.
And I was like, if you,
cause we want to hit all the hotspots.
So I remember--
But that wasn't--
Breaking that plan out for them.
And it was almost like,
okay, Mr Ruin Everyone's Fun.
You know what I'm saying?
That was their take on it.
Their philosophy was let's just go in.
Let's, you don't, why do
we have to get up so early,
and have breakfast, and
get there before people,
and make sure you do this.
Can't we just go in there?
Now there is a balance.
Let me just say there is a balance
because if you take the complete opposite,
no planning, no foresight,
you might go and be like,
we didn't do anything fun.
All I did was wait in two lines all day
'cause I didn't think about this.
But when you get in my,
that's what I'm trying to,
I'm trying to strike the balance.
The balance between being
prepared and having a plan,
but having no expectation
that that plan will be met
and not thinking that success
is the plan being accomplished.
Right.
These certain expectations.
So being prepared, but
having no expectations,
it's like those, those
are two very different--
Maybe we're saying--
I think we're saying the same thing.
Maybe we're saying the same thing.
'Cause I'm like, if I
say my desired outcome
is to enjoy Christy's company
and for her to enjoy mine.
And that means I have to
stay in a certain mind frame.
That's enjoyable, you know.
I can't fall from my
own traps, which make me
someone who's not fun to be
around because I get in my head
about, oh, this isn't
working out, I'm a failure.
But also you stop having fun.
Oh yeah, yeah, definitely.
So it's, if that's my
desired outcome, then it's,
oh, it's not about going
on the right trail,
or getting to this certain place,
or camping at the place
with the most perfect view.
And then if it happens,
you're like, wow, bonus.
Is that the same, is that
similar to what you're saying,
in terms of letting go of expectations?
Yeah. It's the same thing.
I mean, for you, again, I
think this is that whole
enneagram one, enneagram three,
presenting in a very similar way
in the way that they approach things.
For you it might be about controlling it
and doing it perfectly.
And for me it might be a
slightly different twist on that
of just like accomplishing
a certain number of things.
In it's effect, it's
kind of the same thing.
It's like, I'm going into this trip.
I'm thinking that, now I don't have,
and because I am not
trying to go to anything,
other than there's a couple of hot springs
that I definitely want to see.
So if I didn't see those, if
I didn't make it to those,
or something about that
aspect of it was screwed up.
That's gonna present
itself as a disappointment.
But it's not really a sightseeing trip.
It may be the case
that I drive into the
wilderness on day one.
And then I'm just like, I'm
going to stay here for six days.
I'm gonna keep my truck right here.
And I'm just gonna stay here.
And be okay with that.
'Cause being alone and driving,
and being alone in one
place, is a different thing.
I do expect at least one of the places
to be a place that I would be like, okay.
'Cause it's not like every
morning I'm going to wake up.
I'm going to eat some
breakfast really quickly.
And then I'm going to fold my tent up
and just get back on the road.
I fully expect that I'll be like,
well today I'm just going to stay here.
I'm going to sleep in
the same exact place.
At what point do you think
you're going to start
speaking audibly to yourself?
Early on.
Early on, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah. I wonder, I wonder if I would speak.
I'm not even going to, there's
not going to be a time.
I would do that anyway.
Yeah. I think it would,
it would take me a good number of days
before I start speaking
out loud to myself.
But then once I did it,
maybe that would open up a whole
stream of self realization.
Well, the thing is, I'm
trying to figure out
what is the best way to document it.
Again, I often will journal something
and I'll journal it in a way as if
it will be read in the future.
Because I cause, well, case in point,
when we did the the
deconstruction, the lost years,
I read from my journal.
And I am
narcissistic enough to have this idea
that someone will be interested
in reading my journal.
And the idea that for
this thing, it's like,
okay, well what am I going to do?
Am I gonna--
You haven't decided
what you're going to do?
Well I've got multiple options.
I've got, I mean, I'm going
to have my computer with me.
I'm going to take my
computer for typing things.
But I was also, there was
a part of me that was like,
what if I just take a pen and a notebook?
I don't write well, and I get
some carpal tunnel situations
when I try to write,
and I have writer's fatigue with my hand,
and much better at typing.
But then I was like, should
I just do voice memos?
Should I do a video?
Don't do a video because
then you'll tempted
to film it in a way that can
be turned into something.
And then I'm like,
well, I've got my drone.
And it would be really interesting
to get a drone shot of everywhere
I stayed, for my own sake.
But you know, when I'm doing that,
I'm going to be thinking
about, well one day,
not anytime soon, but years
from now, I'll be like,
I went on this trip and
here's all the drone footage.
Maybe next week.
And so that's what I'm
struggling with right now.
'Cause I also have, I've got
my, I've got lots of tech.
So I've got my 360 camera.
So I'm like, okay,
I could do a 360 shot of every campsite.
And that again, I've done that
in the past because it's cool
to be able to put VR
on and be there again.
I think you should do
the 360 camera thing.
That's nice to be able to.
I mean, if you're spending time at a spot
and you're like, you should, I mean,
obviously you're going to journal.
I think that's a good idea.
'Cause then you can, at
certain moments of insight
in my past, it's like, it's nice,
like if I was listening to certain music,
it's nice to put that music back on.
And it's a way to go back there.
So the VR thing is another way,
like literally you could
go back to that spot
if you're listening to music
and you're on VR in the spot again,
it could really, magically,
bring you back to a spot
where it could be special for you.
I think so, I think so.
Like a happy place, or
maybe it's a sad place.
It's a poignant place.
So I think that's a cool idea.
Yeah. The video thing is,
that would be difficult.
But like pictures. I mean, again,
we've talked about this
on a whole episode.
You got to take some
pictures, just do it for you.
Yeah. And again, that's the thing.
It's like, how can I be in
the, and this is it's really,
this is just a microcosm of
what I want my life to be.
And this is a whole 'nother can of worms.
But how can I be in the world in a way
that isn't about look at me
and look at what I can do?
And that's a very
difficult thing for someone
who makes a living saying,
look at what I can do.
Or saying, if you don't look
at what I can do and enjoy it,
then I don't make a living,
I don't have a company.
The hair thing
is an easy place to
point for that quandary.
Because as we discussed, you
have your reasons for doing it,
yet you knew, at the time,
and you've definitely seen it playing out,
that people have to comment
on how big your hair is.
How big your beard is.
That type, so you knew
that it was going to present
some sort of tension.
And I think that there's--
So what's the update?
I'm curious on the update there.
Update on my hair?
Well, I mean, it was, you did
it as a form of embodiment.
It's related to all of these things.
It's like it's a physical
representation of something
that is going on within
you and your mindset.
But you knew that you would,
you have to deal with
people's reaction to it,
response to, it discussion of it.
Well, I think I'm kind
of past the point of,
I'm not past it, in other words.
Yeah, I'm fully aware of that dynamic
and that struggle of it being like,
oh, well people were saying
they really liked my hair.
How do I not gravitate towards
that type of commentary about it?
And actually get something from it.
It's rewarding to have people talk
about how they like your hair, right?
For me, it's more about
this idea that when I
look at pictures before
I grew my hair out,
it feels less like me.
Now, I'm not saying
I'm not going to go back
to short hair or whatever.
I'm not saying I'm gonna
have long hair forever.
But I do think that
part of the exercise was
you have this, I think that life is about,
to use a meme, becoming your final form.
And I think this is what every
religion teaches ultimately.
Is like, you are trying
to continue to move closer to something.
If it's an Eastern philosophy,
it might be enlightenment.
Christianity is like,
you're trying to become
more and more Christlike.
We're kind of talking about
very similar things of,
trying, having some sort
of trajectory in your life.
And for me, this idea of getting
more in touch with myself,
not just being in my head all
the time, following my heart,
I have begun to feel a
cohesiveness with that,
when it comes to having
a big beard and big hair.
So that aspect of it is like,
not mission accomplished,
but sensing that, yes, that
there is something to that.
I feel that I look more,
I think I look more like I
feel about the world now.
So that's the update
is that that has happened to some degree.
I don't know where it's
gonna go from here.
So next week,
next time we record
it will be after the trip.
'Cause we're about to go on these trips.
Who knows, if we'll even
decide to talk about it at all.
It seems like I've got a lot more leeway
to talk about it than
you do, but maybe not.
Well that was the last thing
I was going to say was--
It's not a desired outcome of mine.
I think I have to get to a place where
I can't expect the environment
and the way that the world works to change
in order for me to be okay.
I can't expect people to stop talking
about a change that I make physically.
That's going to continue to happen
whether I'm on camera, on
people's computers, or not.
But I could, but I do believe
I could get to a place
where it really doesn't matter.
And it's not about accolades
or getting some sort of
feedback outside of myself.
It's this idea that what I need
is not some external thing.
It's not some validation.
It's not my environment
being what it should be.
I shouldn't have to curate a solo trip
in order to get to the place
that I want to get to
emotionally, spiritually.
Now those may be helpful to do that.
But ultimately, wouldn't we
all like to get to a place
where, regardless of the circumstances,
you had this equanimity
that you can access, right?
And so I think that
that's the challenge for me,
is go and don't overthink it.
You want to drone, you want
to break the drone out?
Just break the drone
out, do it for yourself.
If you don't do anything
so that you can talk about it or share it,
and then you come back
and you want to talk about it or share it.
Secondarily, go for it.
Right.
Finding that, getting to a place
where you can just be motivated
by, I just wanna do this.
'Cause the only person who's
going to miss out is you.
Right.
Or me.
If that's our mentality.
I mean,
Christy may miss out on some of me
and I may miss out on some of myself
and you might miss out
on some of yourself,
if you're doing things for
the effect or the story.
So maybe you can tell me about it
'cause I'm going to want to know.
But don't think about me
and don't think about
these people listening
while you're out there.
I don't think about you at all.
And let's not get close to any fires.
I'm committed to that.
That's one thing we didn't talk about.
We're not getting close to any fires.
It's not necessarily just
staying away from the fires
that are already happening.
You go into the wrong place in
the forest and a fire starts
and there's one way out,
that could be a whole
different kind of story.
I mean, I didn't--
Neither one of us are going to forests.
I think it is. I'm not going to forests.
I'm not going, well, I
mean, there's going to be
some forest-y areas that
I'm going to be going in.
Well be careful.
But I have thought about this
and here is my take on this.
You tell me if you think
this is a good plan.
If I find myself in a situation
where I wake up in the
middle of night, I'm like,
"Oh crap, there's a
fire coming towards me."
And there's just one dirt
road that came in here.
And I can look down this mountain
and see that the fire is coming towards me
and I got no way out.
Okay.
My theory is you just
drive right through it.
Gosh, I didn't want you to say that
at the end of this podcast.
After everything I just
said was for the effect of,
anyone listening, wouldn't
be worried about it.
Oh my God, I can't wait
until the next Ear Biscuit
to see if they live.
Hold on. Fire burns in a line.
Here, I can this?
I'm saying this, as not,
I'm not an expert on this.
Let me say this.
Just to put you at ease, listener.
If something were happened
to either one of us,
you would have heard about it
before this episode even came out,
this one, this conversation
we're having right now.
So well cut this out if I die in a fire.
That what you're saying?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, but if I lived through it,
this will be pretty awesome.
If you're listening to this,
you know that this didn't happen.
So now you can cut the fool all you want
about driving through a fire.
'Cause it's like--
You're not even supposed to
drive through a flooded street.
Hold on.
But this seems worse.
No. Okay.
If I feel like there's a way
that I can get to a place--
I wouldn't, by the way,
I wouldn't camp anywhere
that there's only one way out.
Well that's the only
the kinds of places I'm going to be, man.
I mean like if the road kept going
and there was a second way
down the mountain or whatever.
That's my advice.
All I'm saying is that
fire burns in a line.
So there's this fire burning,
the perimeter of the fire.
And on the inside of the
perimeter of the fire,
it's not like the whole things of blaze.
It's black. It's just burnt.
It went through and, I
mean, the fire burning zone
is probably no more than a hundred yards.
I'm not going to respond to this.
If you get fast enough.
Sure, both your tires will probably pop.
You may almost cook.
But I'm saying that if
there's no other way out.
I'm driving right through the fire.
I think you should do some research.
And I will film that.
Do some more research.
Okay.
If that's what you're
thinking you're going to do,
do some more research before.
I'm sure it does.
You think you're going to go on some site
and it says, if you find
yourself in this situation,
drive into the fire.
No one in any survival
book is gonna to say,
or suggest, that you could--
So you're joking?
No, I'm saying that they
would never suggest that.
But I'm saying that there's
gotta be circumstances
where that is the thing
that you should do.
Read about it.
Now I don't take my advice,
do your own research.
He is not giving advice.
I'm not giving advice.
This is just my personal philosophy
that I'm conjecturing about.
See, I knew there was an
impending doom feeling
that I had for a reason.
I have a rec.
Rec baby, rec. It's your week.
As we do with many recs,
we tend to recommend things, like movies,
that have been out for awhile
because we just slowly get to things.
So no one's talking about this anymore,
but that's why you should go watch it.
That Andy Sandberg movie, Palm Springs.
I mean, I heard people saying,
you know what, it's a good movie.
It's a really good movie.
It's just a, you know,
it's obviously a comedy.
But it is a, you probably
already know this
because this is how all the trailers
and everything that it's been about.
It's basically an update
on the Groundhog day idea.
And it is so well done.
And it's like, they sat down and thought,
oh man, let's revisit this concept
of somebody being stuck in a time loop.
But really just think about it in a way
that any conversations
that people have had
over the past 30 years
about Groundhog day,
let's put some of those
things into a movie.
And you'll understand when you watch it.
But also it really asked
some interesting questions,
like not real directly,
they're pretty subtle,
the idea of the meaning of
life, and how you find purpose,
and where that comes comes from.
And I just really enjoyed it.
Huh?
Palm Springs.
How long is it? It's not too long is it?
An hour and a half.
Okay.
Again, all the good movies
are an hour and a half now.
Maybe even 85 minutes.
You got to get up--
You don't have to watch the credits.
If you can't tell the story
in 90 minutes in 2020,
then you probably
shouldn't make the movie.
I mean, that's my new philosophy.
Unless you're Zack Snyder.
Yeah, okay.
What, is he making three hour movies?
I think the Snyder cut was like,
it's like four hours or something,
the way that they're releasing it.
Okay, you know what, I
might check that out.
Palm Springs, Andy Sandberg.
It's, I have a problem
watching Andy Sandberg.
Because I have this weird
thing where it's like,
he was, he's in Lonely Island.
We used to have all these comparisons, I,
you guys are like Lonely
Island, but not as funny
It'd be like, you're right.
Yeah. I mean just embrace it, man.
I know, and then, it's like,
it makes me not like to enjoy him.
That's my own problem.
I will enjoy.
He's really good in it.
He's definitely better than we would be.
Yeah.
Okay. I'll check it out.
#EarBiscuits, wish us
luck, even though, again--
I'm not going to drive through a fire,
don't worry about it.
We're already back
and we're still alive.
And maybe we'll talk
about it next episode.
Maybe we'll talk about why we're
not going to talk about it,
but we'll, you'll get an update.
We'll talk about something.
#EarBiscuits
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget
to click on the circular
icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.